as demand for takeaway meals soared
during europe's covid19 lockdowns
delivery riders with branded backpacks
have become a common site in towns and
cities
since launching in london in 2013
deliveroo
now operates in 54 cities across 13
different countries
but delivers stock flotation has given
some investors indigestion
and filled many of these riders with
indignation
often i'll go out in peak times thursday
night friday night and i might be
waiting 40 minutes for a job
when that job comes through it might be
three pounds 50 something like that
and i might not get another bite for
another hour you know so two hours work
i've had three pounds fifty or seven
pounds
in what should be peak times so it's not
sustainable
these striking riders are just a few
hundred among the fifty thousand riders
that work for deliveroo in the uk
but coming just a few weeks after the uk
supreme court
ordered the ride-hailing app uber to
treat its drivers as
workers the message about rights and
conditions in the so-called gig economy
is having an impact at a corporate level
this demonstration by delivery riders is
far more than just a symbolic
gesture the buoyancy of the share price
among
retail investors has not been shared
with institutional investors many of
whom
are still concerned about the model of
the gig economy
industry these riders are here today to
demand
better pay better rights and better
safety you know they've worked
throughout the pandemic
they've literally put their lives on the
line while they've seen their company
business boom uh yet they've seen pain
conditions get worse and worse
throughout the pandemic
after planning to launch at 460 pence
per share
delivery floated last week at 390 pence
and immediately dropped even further to
280 pets
that's still a valuation of more than
six billion dollars
but several big name institutional
investors have decided to steer clear
investors are demanding a higher
standard
for for workers particularly in gig
economy style
practices um really in terms of the
exact extent of what this is going to
mean
for companies is really hard hard to
predict
the indications are that deliveries so
called retail investors have chosen to
hang on to the stock instead of dumping
it
and the share price rose by a modest two
percent in early trading on wednesday
the liver hasn't yet published financial
results for 2020
and the apparent boom in the delivery
business during the pandemic year could
well bounce the share price back
up but the workers who made that
possible are demanding their share
of the success paul brennan al jazeera
shoreditch
east london